I've been craving a salmon bowl for so
long now it's really easy to make and
you can pretty much add any ingredients
to the bowl that you like so start by
slicing the salmon into large chunks and
I'm making a teriyaki sauce with equal
parts soy sauce Marin and sake and add
sugar depending on how sweet you want it
set this aside to marinate and keep a
third of the sauce for later then I'm
making a spicy mayo sauce with keepime
mayo sriracha and sugar the ratio is up
to you add more Sriracha if you like it
spicy and sugar depending on your taste
then I'm reducing the teriyaki sauce
which is all on top clean the pan so it
doesn't stick and cook the salmon to
your doneness I like to put mine to a
medium rare then I'm adding half rice
and a half salad adding footicake to
season my rice along with avocado and
cucumbers and a drizzle of spicy mayo